[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les journées passent vite pour higuain
est la bouche pas mal puis on commence
avec beaucoup beaucoup de réservations
il est propriétaire de centres de pêche
à saint sulpice depuis cinq ans mais la
demande est telle qu'il a décidé
d'ouvrir un autre emplacement ou vieux
port de montréal cette année j'ai
beaucoup des nouveaux pêcheurs deux audi
vient de pêcher c'est la première fois
que nokia rim ont l'odeur d'un qu'au psg
gagne en popularité
les ventes de permis de pêche au québec
ont augmenté au cours des dernières
années passant de 700 9000 en 2019 à
sept cent soixante sept mille en 2021
ici plusieurs petits apprentis pêcheurs
se prépare à
manger les poissons et au delà de
l'activité la possibilité de consommer
ces prises et voilà
mon bonheur
on compte environ 118 espèces de
poissons dans les eaux douces du québec
bien que toutes les espèces soit
comestibles une trentaine représente
l'intérêt culinaire est ici dans les
eaux du fleuve saint laurent on retrouve
plus de 80 espèces de poissons toutes à
la même question est ce qu'on peut
garder le poisson et oui on est aidé à
faciliter examen à nanterre qu'elle
s'efface et l'élévation je trouve vos
lots ben il veut pas les ménages se dit
écoute ça commence à coûter cher les
loyers ont doublé triplé
l'essence a doublé avec le monde vont
chercher des alternatives différents en
essais en s'amusant en effet le prix du
panier d'épicerie a augmenté de
76,9 % depuis 1995 et c'est la viande
qui a le plus augmenté
résultat l'intérêt pour les poissons des
six se fait de plus en plus sentir sur
la glace et aussi dans les épiceries
chez métro par exemple la direction
confirme que les ventes de poissons
connu une bonne augmentation cours des
deux dernières années spécialement les
produits canadiens
même son de cloche chez les poissonniers
chambre rennes a ouvert son commerce il
ya deux ans il a fait le choix de
privilégier des produits locaux par
exemple le doré en haute saison 90 % de
ces produits proviennent du québec et
des maritimes
oui une très très forte devant les gens
demandent les poissons du québec il ya
des poissons qui voulait mettre du
sommeil ou pas du québec ils vont se
retourner vers un autre poisson que lui
du québec je suis d'elmo chez delmon une
véritable institution à montréal on
offre des produits de la mer et du doré
depuis 1934 celui-ci d'apt 64 filet de
doré monial à 2 et 10 les prix ont
augmenté avec les années mais la demande
est toujours là le doré évidemment qui
le poisson le plus vendu sauf que la
vente commerciale du douar y est
interdite au québec malgré sa popularité
grandissante ce que je peux avoir de
plus frais ça vient de l'ontario pour le
doré mais si je pouvais l'avoir des
laurentides mais c'est sûr ce sera
encore mieux
[Musique]
du haut de ses 10 ans luna n'a pas
l'intention d'aller à l'épicerie ou au
restaurant pour manger du poisson
thon j'aime tous les poissons j'ai
vraiment manger les animaux les animaux
qui sont amers la déterminer c'est ici
avec son père dans les eaux du fleuve
quel temps en train de pêcher son souper
ici marie michèle osant radio canada
montréal